تعلن تقدمها بالمنطقه الصناعيه بباخموت
وتقول انها سيطرت على مصانع للمعادن
البرلمان الروسي يناقش تعديلات تجيز سحب
الجنسيه ممن ينتقد العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
تشدد الاشتباكات بين الامن الباكستاني
وانصار عمران خان المطلوبه اعتقاله بامر
قضائي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلنت مجموعه فاقنر الروسيه
تحقيق قواتها تقدما جديدا في المنطقه
الصناعيه بباخمت التي تشهد قتالا عنيفا مع
تحسن القوات الاوكرانيه داخلها وذكرت
فاغنفي بيان لها ان قوتها خاضت قتالا
ليليا عنيفا وصعبا ضد القوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه وسط بخموت وتمكنت من السيطره على
مصانع للمعادن واقتربت من السيطره على
اربعه مواقع جديده داخل
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي بعد
اجتماعه بالقاده العسكريين اكدت تاييد
بالاجماع لمواصله الدفاع عن بخمت في دنيا
تلقيت تقاريرا من القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه تفيد بان محور الاهتمام الرئيسي
في باخموت وزابروجيا ولدينا موقف واضح
التعزيز العسكري في هذا القطاع وتدمير
المحتلين الى اقصى حد كما تلقينا معلومات
حول دونيتسك بالاضافه الى المناطق
الجنوبيه والشماليه نحن نزود هذه المناطق
بالضخيره والاسلحه الروتينيه في الاثناء
افاد المكتب التمثيلي لدونيت بان القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه قصف ثلاث مناطق منها
احد عشر مره خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه كما
اطلقت ما يصل الى 50 قطعه ذخيره مختلفه
العيارات المكتب التمثيلي لدنياتسك اوضح
ايضا ان الهجمات الاوكرانيه تسببت باصابه
ثلاثه مدنيين في مدينه كرفسكي
جدد السفير الروسي في واشنطن اناتولي
انتونوف تاكيده بان المسيره او المسيره
الامريكيه التي سقطت فوق البحر الاسود
اتجهت بثبات وبشكل استفزازي باتجاه
الاراضي الروسيه وقال في بيان نشرته
السفاره ان المسيرات الامريكيه تجمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه التي تستخدمها
كياف بعد ذلك لضرب روسيا واشدد انتونوف
على ضروره وقف الولايات المتحده ارسال اي
مقاتلات او مسيرات جويه بالقرب من الحدود
الروسيه واشار الى ان انشطه الجيش
الامريكي على مقربه شديده من حدود روسيا
غير مقبوله وتثير القلق
وصف زعيم الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكيه تشاك شومر قرارات الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وجيشه بالاعمال
الطائشه محذرا بوتين من ان السلوك الروسي
قد يؤدي لتصعيد غير مقصود مع امريكا
اخر يقوم به الرئيس بوتين وجيشه اود ان
اقول للسيد بوتين اوقف هذا السلوك قبل ان
تكون سببا في تصعيد غير مقصود شهدنا هذا
السلوك الروسي من قبل ولي يمنعنا من تنفيذ
عمليات فوق البحر الاسود هذه الاعمال
العدوانيه من قبل الطائرات الروسيه محفوفه
بالمخاطر ويمكن ان تؤدي مثل ما ذكرت الى
تصعيد غير مقصود الطائرات الامريكيه تحلق
بشكل روتيني فوق البحر الاسود قبل غزو
بوتين المتهور لاوكرانيا وانا واثق من ان
جيشنا سيستمر في القيام بذلك
قال تقرير للصحيفه وعشنتم بوست ان القوه
العسكريه لاوكرانيا متدهوره بعد عام من
الحرب اذ تدور الشكوك حول قدرتكاف في شن
هجوم في الربيع المقبل
بين هذه الخطوط والعاصمه كييف يدور شك في
قدره الاخيره على شن هجوم مضاد في الربيع
كما قالت وتتحضر
فعام من الحرب انهت جيشها وافقده الافا من
ذوي الخبره القتاليه
في احدث التقارير الغربيه فان حاله القوه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه متدهوره بسبب حجم
الاصابات التي اخرجت العديد من المقاتلين
الاكثر خبره من ساحه المعركه
يرجع مسؤولون اوروبيون وامريكيون حاله
التدهور هذه لعده اسباب
فخلال عام وقع 120 الف جندي اوكراني بين
قتيل وجريح جلهم من ذوي الخبره القتاليه
حجم الخساره هذا دفع كييف للدفع بمجندين
عديم الخبره لسد النقص على خطوط القتال
اضافه للنقص الاساسي في الذخيره
وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست فان الاشهر
القادمه تشكل تحديا امام كييف لاستعاده
زمام المبادره وشن هجوم في هذا الوضع الذي
يعاني فيه جيشها من نقص في العدد والعتاد
بالمقابل فان حال الجيش الروسي ليس بافضل
حال وان كان عدده يشكل ثلاثه اضعاف جيش
اوكرانيا
فوفقا للتقديرات الغربيه ذاتها فقد خسرت
موسكو قرابه 200 الف جندي بين قتيل وجريح
اضافه لمشاكل في الذخيره والقوى العامله
وما بين تشكيك بقدره كييف وموسكو على
الهجوم والدفاع فان التقديرات تقول ان
عاما من الحرب انهك الجيشين وان عاما
جديدا بدا لتوهه ايضا بالحديد والنار
افاد النائب الاول لرئيس لجنه مجلس ادومه
قسطنطين زاتولين بوجود تعديلات على قانون
الجنسيه الروسي التعديل يتضمن الحرمان من
الجنسيه الروسيه المكتسبه في حاله الخيانه
وتشويه سمعه العمليه العسكريه الجاريه
باوكرانيا بحسب المسؤول الروسي لوكاله
مشروع القانون كذلك على الحرمان من
الجنسيه بسبب جرائم خطيره ضد الدوله
وجرائم متعلقه بالاتجار بالمخدرات وتزوير
الوثائق
يلتقي اليوم رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي
انطونيو البانيز او البانيز بنظيره الفيجي
ويليام في مدينه صوفا لتاكيد رساله كامبرا
بان برنامجها للغواصات التي تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه لا يتعارض مع التزاماتها بالحد من
الانتشار النووي العالمي استراليا مع
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا اتفاقيه اوكوس
بقيمه 245 مليار دولار لشراء ثلاث غواصات
قبل ان تتحول الى انتاج غواصه جديده
تتواصل التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين
كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده حيث
اجرت قوات بريه للبلدين مناوره على انشاء
جسور لعبور دبابات في محاكاه لاشتباك بريء
وقال مسؤولون عسكريون ان واشنطن وسيول
عززت تعاون الدفاعي في مواجهه التهديدات
العسكريه والنوويه المتزايده من كوريا
الشماليه ضمن التدريبات درع الحريه
في تايوان تعهد المرشح الرئاسي المحتمل
للحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي ويلياملاي
بحمايه الجزيره ضد الصين وضمان السلام
لاياكد تسجيله رسميا لخوض الانتخابات
التمهيديه الرئاسيه مشيرا الى ان تايوان
وقفت على الخطوط الاماميه للديمقراطيه كما
اتهم الصين بتوجيه تهديدات لفظيه وعسكريه
مباشره ضد تايوان
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
جلسه استجواب اليوم لحاكم مصر في لبنان
رياض سلامه في قضايا اختلاس عامه
اهلا بكم من جديد تجددت الاشتباكات بين
قوات الامن الباكستانيه وانصار رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان اليوم الثاني
على التوالي وتحاول قوات من الشرطه التقدم
نحو مقر اقامه عمران خان لاعتقاله بامر
قضائي لكن من دون جدوى بسبب التسوق الذي
يفرده انصاره حول مسكنه
[تصفيق]
واوضح رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان بانه تعهد ضمنيا بانه سيمتل
امام المحكمه في الثامن عشر من مارس مؤكدا
انه هو بحسب الماده السادسه والسبعين من
قانون الاجراءات الجنائيه لا يحق لهم
القبض عليه
اليوم قدمت تعهدا من خلال اشتياق خان رئيس
محكمه لاهور العليا حاول تسليمه الى نائب
المفتش العامل الشرطه الذي كان قادما
لاعتقالي كما ادلى بتصريح علني مفرده ان
نائب المفتش لم يقابله عمدا وفقا للماده
السادسه والسبعين من قانون الاجراءات
الجنائيه اذا كان قد تم تسليم هذه الكفاله
فلا يمكن القبض علي بعدها
ومن اسلام اباد ينضم الينا مراسل العربي
عبد الرحمن المزيني اهلا بك عبد الرحمن
يعني يتجددت الاشتباكات اليوم الثاني على
التوالي في اسلام اباد ولكن هل تاكد وجود
عمران خان داخل مقره المحاصر
عمران خان لا يزال في مقر اقامته في مدينه
لاهور عاصمه اقليم البنجاب الشرقي البلاد
الاشتباكات المتقطعه بين قوات الامن
الباكستانيه وانصار رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان لا تزال مستمره
كلما تحاول قوات الامن التقدم نحو مقر
اقامه رئيس الوزراء السابق يقوم انصار
رئيس وزراء عمران خان بالقاء الحجاره على
قوات الامن التي
تستخدم اعايره الغاز المسيل للدموع
وخراطيم المياه لتفريق المتظاهرين الوضع
لا يزال متوترا في مدينه لاهور رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
علق امالا على المؤسسه العسكريه بالتدخل
لوقف او انهاء ما وصفها بالمهزله التي
بياكد على ان القضايا المرفوعه ضده
ومذكرات الاعتقال بحقه غير قانونيه ولا
يوجد مسوق لاعتقاله قال بانه قد حذر من ان
الاوضاع قد تخرج عن السيطره وقال ان
انصاره لم يعودوا يستمع له في حال استمرت
اصطدامات بينهم وبين قوات الامن
الباكستانيه على سياق متصل محكمه اسلام
اباد محكمه استعمالات العليا بدات النظر
في التماس قدمه الفريق القانوني لعمران
خان
لوقف العمل بمذكره الاعتقال ضدها كان هناك
اعتراضات من قبل محرر السجل في المحكمه
لكن القضيه لا تزال جاريه وربما الساعات
المقبله سوف توضح ما ان كان سيتم اعتقال
عمران خان او منحه كفاله ضد الاعتقال عبد
الرحمن يعني عمر ان خان يستند بدفاع عن
نفسه او عدم قدره السلطات الامنيه على
اعتقاله على الماده السادسه والسبعين من
قانون الاجراءات الجنائيه على ماذا تنص
هذه الماده ولما يعني يحتمي بها
حقيقه هناك في القانون الباكستاني
للمتهم هناك عده خطوات او اجراءات يمكنه
القيام بها
للحيلوله دون اعتقاله منها من بين هذه
الماده لكن التوقيت الذي
كتب فيه رئيس الوزراء السابق هذا التعهد
كان في وقت متاخر في ساعات الصباح الاولى
من هذا اليوم بلا شك معظم المقر الحكوميه
مغلقه هناك اجراءات قانونيه يجب ان تمر
بها هذا يمر بها هذا التعهد اضافه الى
المذكرات او عفوا الالتماسات التي قدمها
الى المحاكم الباكستاني المختلفه للحصول
على كفاله هذه يعني هذا هناك اجراءات
قضائيه يجب
المرور بها للحصول على الكفاله لكن السؤال
هو ان القضاء الباكستاني منح رئيس وزراء
السابق عمران خان عده فرص للوصول امام
المحكمه ومنعها عده كفالات لكنه يرفض او
كان يتخلف عن حضور هذه الجلسات الامر الذي
لم يعد امام قضاه هذه المحاكم سوى اصدار
مذكره اعتقال لاتمام العمليه القضائيه
واكمال الاجراءات المحاكمه في القضاء التي
يواجهها شكرا جزيلا لك من اسلام اباد
مراسل العربي عبد الرحمن المسيني
التقى رئيس مجلس الوزراء محمد شاع
السوداني في اربيل رئيس الاقليم برزاني
ورئيس الحكومه مسرور برزاني وقال بيان
للمكتب الاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء انه جرى
خلال اللقاء بحث عدد من القضايا والملفات
المشتركه والتاكيد على العمل المشترك
والتعاون لحل كل الاشكالات بين بغداد
واربيل واضاف البيان ان الحكومه تمتلك
الاراده والرغبه الجاده في انهاء الملفات
العالقه وبشكل جذري والانتقال الى افق
واسع من العمل المشترك والفرص الاقتصاديه
التي تعود بالخير على ابناء الشعب العراقي
في كردستان وكل المحافظات
افادت مصادر قضائيه لبنانيه للعربيه بانه
ستعقد اليوم جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصر في
لبنان رياض سلامه امام القاضي شربل ابو
سمره في قضايا اختلاس اموال عامه مضيفه ان
الجلسه ستتم في قصر عادل بيروت واكد
المصدر نفسه انه من المنتظر ان يحضر سلامي
شخصيا الجلسه لانه وكلاءه القانونيين لم
يقدموا دفوعا شكليه بحضورهم نيابه عنه وان
التحقيق معه سيكون بحضور قادم فرنسي من
ضمن وفد المحققين الاوروبيين الموجودين في
لبنان
[موسيقى]
بعد سته اشهر لا تزال الاحتجاجات التي عمت
الشوارع الايرانيه منذ مقتل الشاب الكرديه
مهسه امينه مستمره
مسا اميني شعله لم تنطفئ في ايران بعد سته
اشهر على مقتلها اتهمت بانها ترتدي لباسا
غير لائق ثم اقتيدت الى مركز الشرطه ثم
قتلت
لتسبب وفاتها موجه احتجاجات لا تزال
مستمره حتى اليوم
فالاصوات التي ملات شوارع المدن الايرانيه
لا مطلب لها سوى العداله والحريه
والمساواه
الغضب الذي اشعلته وفاه مهسى ترافق مع
سلسله مشاكل خصوصا الازمه الاقتصاديه
وسلوك شرطه الاخلاق
احتجاجات اعتقل فيها الالاف واعدم العشرات
في خطوه قالت المعارضه انها لترهيب
المحتجين
وفي ظل حربها المستمره على المراه اغلقت
حركه طالبان المكتبه النسائيه الوحيده في
العاصمه كابول بعد سته اشهر فقط على
افتتاحها
حطوا المكتبه هنا في كابول لم تسلم طالما
ارتبط اسمها بالنساء فحرب طالبان على
المراه لم تتوقف بعد وتطالب كل ما يتعلق
بها
في احدث فصول هذه الحرب اقدمت حركه طالبان
على اغلاق المكتبه النسائيه الوحيده في
العاصمه الافغانيه بعد سته اشهر فقط من
افتتاحها مسؤول المكتبه قالوا انهم
اغلقوها لاسباب امنيه وفرض قيود على
النساء من قبل حركه طالبان الى جانب تعرض
المكتبه للهجوم مرتين من قبل طالبان
لتنتهي القصه باغلاقها نهائيا
اغلاق المكتبه التي شكلت الملجا الوحيد
للفتيات في كابو يقابله اصرار من النساء
على افتتاح مكتبات سريه ردا على اقصاء
طالبان الممنهج له مع التوجه الحاد للحركه
في القضاء على حقوق المراه تتضائل الامال
في تاثير التحركات الدوليه للضغط على
السلطه حرمت النساء ليس من العمل والتعليم
فقط بل وحتى ارتياد المرافق العامه
والترفيهيه في اخر تحرك دولي تجاه ما
تمارسه الحركه فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الثامن من الشهر الجاري عقوبات عن وزير
التعليم العالي في طالبان لدى محمد نديم
بسبب مسؤوليته عن الانتهاك الواسع لحق
المراه في التعليم وزير اعلن علنا انه
يريد قتل كل ما يخالفه
عن خبير يعمل بوزاره الموارد البشريه
الصينيه ان الصين تخطط لرفع سن التقاعد
بشكل تدريجيا وعلى مراحل للتعامل مع زياده
اعداد كبار السن في البلاد
للتعامل مع زياده اعداد كبار السن الصين
تخطط لرفع سن التقاعد سيكون الرفع على
مراحل وبشكل تدريجي وسائل اعلام صينيه
اكدت ان من قارب سن التقاعد سيكون عليه
تاجيله والميزه هي السماح للافراد باختيار
موعد التقاعد بناء على ظروف الشخص الاتجاه
لرفع سن التقاعد ياتي بعد تراجع عدد
السكان وتقدم الاعمار ما يسبب الضغط على
ميزانيات المعاشات خصوصا بعد التوقعات
بتضاعف اعداد من هم اكثر من 60 عاما بحلول
الفين وخمسه وثلاثين
الان هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تؤكد بان
المعارك في بخمه مستمره ونتمسك بمواقعنا
فيها اصدرت رئيسه بيرو دينابول وورد
انذارا احمرا للعاصمه لما والمناطق
المحيطه بها بعد الدمار الناجم عن اعصار
يعقو الذي ضرب البلاد الاعصار تسبب بسقوط
سته قتلى على الاقل في المحافظات الشماليه
وترك عشرات الاسر بلا منازل كما ان سيول
الامطار تهدد باحداث دمار في اجزاء كثيره
من منطقه العاصمه مع توقعات الارصاد
الجويه في بيرو بمغادره الاعصار اراضي
البلاد خلال الايام القليله المقبله
[موسيقى]
نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن مصادر مطلعه ان
التطبيق تيك توك سوف يدرس امكانيه
الانفصال عن شركه
الصينيه وذكرت الوكاله بان قرار الانفصال
تيك توك عن الشركه الصينيه ياتي بهدف
تبديد المخاوف بشان مخاطر الامن القومي
الا انه هو بحسب المصادر يتعين على
الحكومه الصينيه الموافقه اولا على انفصال
تيك توك عن
نشره تفكيرهم
[موسيقى]
فاجنر تعلن تقدمها بالمنطقه الصناعيه
بباخموت وتقول انها سيطرت على مصانع
للمعادن
البرلمان الروسي يناقش تعديلات تجيز سحب
الجنسيه ممن ينتقد العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
تجدد الاشتباكات بين الامن الباكستاني
وانصار عمران خان المطلوب اعتقاله بامر
قضائي
اراكم على راس الساعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]